herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zum gemeinsamen statement der
bundesminister heil und altmaier
wir werden zuerst mit den high beginnen
dann wird herr altmaier sein statement
abgeben danach haben wir zeit für drei
nachfragen in meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die korona krise ist in
deutschland angekommen und sie ist
zweifellos ein kraftakt für unser land
das krisenmanagement der bundesregierung
hat prioritäten
unser ziel ist es schaden von der
bevölkerung abzuwenden und entschlossen
und frühzeitig zu handeln
unser ziel ist es die gesundheit unserer
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen und
auch wirtschaft und arbeitsplätze zu
sichern
dazu haben wir heute im schnellverfahren
einen gesetzentwurf beschlossen
das heißt im umlageverfahren im kabinett
der einen schutzschirm für arbeitsplätze
in deutschland ermöglicht worum geht es
und was ist das problem
wir leben und wir haben darüber
gesprochen in vielerlei hinsicht
wirtschaftliche störungen
da geht es beispielsweise um die
nachricht dass die lufthansa die hälfte
ihrer flügel weltweit streicht es geht
aber auch um probleme in der
zulieferkette wenn beispielsweise teil
aus norditalien in deutschland
verarbeitet werden sollen und im moment
nicht ankommen
es geht um die folgen die die absagen
von messen beispielsweise für den hotel-
und gaststättenbereich für die tourismus
auch haben
es geht hin und wieder dann
möglicherweise auch die situation dass
aufgrund von anordnung von
gesundheitsämtern betriebe länger nicht
offen sind und wirtschaftliche
schwierigkeiten kommen für all das haben
wir instrumente und das betrifft vor
allen dingen die bestehenden und
zukünftigen regeln für das thema
kurzarbeit
ich will darauf hinweisen dass jetzt
schon sofort ohne änderungen kurzarbeit
in deutschland angemeldet werden kann
für die unternehmen die das brauchen
aber wir werden als bundesregierung mit
dem gesetzentwurf den wir heute auf den
weg bringen zügig ermöglichen dass wir
den zugang zur kurzarbeitergeld für
unternehmen und beschäftigte erleichtern
im einzelnen ist es bisher so dass
mindestens ein drittel der beschäftigten
in einem betrieb von arbeitsausfall
betroffen sein muss wir werden diese
schwelle
auf 10 prozent senken zweitens wir
werden auch dafür sorgen dass
leiharbeiterinnen und leiharbeiter in
kurzarbeit gehen können wenn das
notwendig ist weil wir auch vermuten
dass das eine gruppe sein kann
die als erstes von arbeitsplatzverlusten
betroffen werden kann und drittens die
arbeitgeber müssen zukünftig keine
sozialversicherungsbeiträge mehr zahlen
das heißt wir in dem mehr geld in die
hand um unternehmen und beschäftigten zu
helfen um arbeitsplätze zu sichern
der koalitionsausschuss hat am sonntag
beschlossen das ist auch das ziel der
bundesregierung dass wir diese
herausforderung nicht nur annehmen
sondern bewältigen unser ziel ist es in
dieser situation kein arbeitsplatz
möglichst kein arbeitsplatz und auch
kein unternehmen dauerhaft schaden nimmt
und deshalb bauen wir jetzt brücken und
meine damen und herren deutschland hat
erfahrung mit solchen brücken wir
gemeinsam haben die erfahrung an die
finanzkrise 2008 9 die war anders
gelagert
aber wir haben auch damals veränderte
regeln zur kurzarbeit angesetzt damals
was ein dramatischer einbruch der
wirtschaftsleistung unseres landes - 5
prozent und es gab eben keinen tsunami
am arbeitsmarkt sondern wirtschaft
gewerkschaften und staat haben
gemeinschaftlich verantwortlich
gehandelt
und deshalb werden wir das jetzt auch
tun wir zeigen dass wir schnell handeln
können wir wollen unbürokratisch handeln
und schnell um unternehmen und
beschäftigten zu helfen
mein ziel ist unser ziel ist als
bundesregierung dass wir dieses gesetz
jetzt in einem schnellen verfahren auch
umsetzen
das kabinett hat wie gesagt heute
beschlossen die fraktionen
regierungsfraktionen werden heute
nachmittag beraten über eine parallele
einbringung im deutschen bundestag
wir sind wenn der bundestag und der
bundesrat mitmachen in der lage dieses
auch zügig parlamentarisch umzusetzen
und unser ziel ist dass für das anfang
april in der ersten aprilhälfte dann
auch wirksam werden lassen können
ich will noch mal betonen dass in
solchen zeiten wir zusammenstehen müssen
bei allen interessen unterschieden die
es in der wirtschaft in der politik auch
geben mag ob sie jetzt christdemokrat
oder sozialdemokrat sind ob sie chef
oder mitarbeiter sind ob sie wirtschaft
oder gewerkschaften sind und deshalb
wird die bundesregierung wie am
sonntagabend auch verabredet die
sozialpartner zügig an den tisch holen
wir werden
beraten über den die umsetzung von
kurzarbeitsregelungen der kollege
altmaier und der kollege finanzminister
olaf scholz sind auch in gesprächen das
liquiditäts fragen betrifft aber heute
wie gesagt ist ein wichtiger schritt auf
dem weg mit diesem veränderten gesetz
und wir wollen ein stück sicherheit in
dieser situation damit auch deutlich
machen
ich will auch mal sagen dass wir die
finanziellen ressourcen haben das zu
schultern ohne dass wir auf den
bundeshaushalt zurückgreifen müssen
durch die gute wirtschaftliche
entwicklung der letzten jahre und die
tatsache dass wir rücklagen gebildet
haben stehen bei der bundesagentur für
arbeit für den notfall insgesamt 26
milliarden euro rücklagen zur verfügung
das heißt sie haben den puffer solche
brücken zu bauen und er ist genau für
solche fälle auch gedacht ja vielen dank
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich bin dem kollegin hubertus heil sehr
dankbar dass dieser gesetzentwurf in
sehr schneller zeit fertig geworden ist
wir setzen damit den beschluss des
koalitionsausschusses und der gesamten
bundesregierung um und es liegt mir
daran deutlich zu machen dass hubertus
heil als arbeitsministerin peter
altmaier als wirtschaftsminister in
dieser frage an einem strang ziehen ich
unterstütze die getroffene regelung voll
und ganz
es geht in der tat um den erhalt von
arbeitsplätzen und damit um eine
sozialpolitische maßnahme aber es geht
auch um den erhalt von unternehmen und
innerhalb von wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
das ist eine wirtschaftspolitische
maßnahme ersten ranges insofern ist
dieser einigkeit die wir in der letzten
woche bereits bei den ersten
vorgesprächen an den tag gelegt haben
und die uns getragen hat über den
koalitionsausschuss eine notwendige
voraussetzung dafür dass wir mit der
krise angemessen umgehen
sie alle erleben im stundentakt die
meldungen aus europäischen
nachbarländern aber auch aus
bundesländern die darauf hindeuten dass
wir eben den höhepunkt der
herausforderungen noch nicht erreicht
haben es ist eine ungewöhnlich ernste
lage
und sie stellt große voraussetzungen an
verantwortliches handeln der beteiligten
ich habe in der vergangenen woche einen
drei stufen plan vorgelegt der
inzwischen nicht nur bei der
bundesregierung sondern auch bei den
länder wirtschaftsministern auf große
zustimmung gestoßen ist wir befinden uns
derzeit in der ersten und zweiten stufe
dieses planes das kurzarbeitergeld gibt
es ja bisher auch schon aber es war
notwendig es so anzupassen dass es vor
allen dingen auch auf die
konjunkturellen probleme stärker bezug
länder nicht nur auf die strukturellen
fragen für die wir es im gesetzentwurf
ursprüngliche ausgerichtet hatten
es ist wichtig und da bin ich schon bald
ebenfalls dankbar dass wir die
zeitarbeit mit einbeziehen das war
bisher nicht der fall aber zeitarbeit
ist zum einen ein wichtiges ins
flexibilitäts instrument für unternehmen
und für die wirtschaft in krisenzeiten
und zum anderen geht es auch dort um
beschäftigte und um deren individuelle
schicksale und beides bringen wir unter
einen hut ich habe mich heute morgen in
zusammen drei stunden lang ausgetauscht
mit den wirtschaftsministern und
wirtschafts senatoren der bundesländer
in einer sondersitzung wir waren uns
einig dass die von hubertus heil und der
bundesregierung vorgelegte regelung
notwendig ist dass sie in die richtige
richtung geht und dass jede
unterstützung verdient und ich kann
ihnen versichern dass wir auch in
zukunft sowohl gemeinsam mit dem
kollegen olaf scholz wie auch gemeinsam
mit dem kollegen jens spahn und sowieso
bertus heil zu jedem zeitpunkt die
notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen werden
um ruhig und besonnen aber eben auch
entschlossen das zu tun was wir tun
müssen nämlich zu verhindern dass das
corona virus auch die wirtschaft
infiziert wir haben alle hände voll zu
tun die gesundheitlichen
herausforderungen zu meistern
und deshalb ist es für uns wichtig und
notwendig dass deutschland eine
leistungsstarke volkswirtschaft auch in
der zukunft bleibt das können wir
erreichen indem wir schritt für schritt
den betroffenen unternehmen die
hilfestellungen geben die sie notwendig
haben und gegebenenfalls dafür auch die
instrumente entsprechend aufstocken
die erste frage hatte ernst
zahlen zur ersten frage ich bin mit
einem genauen datum ein bisschen
vorsichtig also mit einem genauen
stichtag weil wir jetzt den deutschen
bundestag und dem bundesrat auch im
zügiges verfahren bitten müssen aber wir
rechnen damit dass das bei guten willen
bei frisst verzicht bei raschem handeln
gelingt das wir anfang april mit dem
gesetz fertig sind parallel werden wir
an der verordnung die wir dann als
ermächtigung bekommen arbeiten sie zügig
in kraft setzen so dass die
vereinbarungen der koalition in der
ersten aprilhälfte umgesetzt werden kann
und wenn ich erst aprilhälfte sage dann
sage ich das licht eher richtung anfang
april als richtung mitte april
aber ich bitte um verständnis dass wir
da noch ein paar tage brauchen wir
müssen auch die technische umsetzung mit
der bundesagentur für arbeit klären
es ist jetzt so dass auf wachsend immer
mehr unternehmen anfragen haben zu
diesem thema ich will noch mal darauf
hinweisen es gibt bestehende regel zu
kurzarbeit wird das ganz schnell
brauchen die voraussetzungen hat kann
jetzt schon auch ziehen und wir werden
auch was den inhalt der
verordnungsermächtigung trifft in dem
wir arbeiten ganz rasch arbeiten um
sicherheit da auch rein zu bringen
die frage welche branchen betroffen sind
herr hansen sind sehr vielfältige
nachrichten ich habe ja vorhin paar
genannt wir haben zuerst durch die
ankündigung dass messen aus
gesundheitlichen gründen eingeschränkt
werden nachrichten bekommen aus dem
bereich messebau beispielsweise aber
auch aus dem hotel und
gaststättengewerbe das geht bis hin zu
catering wir haben dann die beispiele
von lieferketten störungen weniger
übrigens aus china bisher aber mehr aus
neuwied
zb in der zulieferindustrie maschinenbau
und in der automobilindustrie ist das
der fall
wir haben zudem jetzt die ankündigung
von großunternehmen wie der lufthansa
dich freuen genannt habe aus dem bereich
logistik kommen nachrichten also es
kommt aus der unterschiedlichen
bereichen und wir müssen auch das ist
vorsorglich deshalb ist es besonders
jetzt zu handeln
diese regeln haben für den fall dass das
ganze welt wirtschaftliche folgen hat
die wir heute nicht absehen können
frühzeitiges handeln gibt sicherheit und
das ist das was wir haben
wir haben zudem darauf will ich
hinweisen durch teil störungen die wir
unabhängig von corona ja auch schon
hatten durch handelspolitische
unsicherheiten durch diskussionen über
rückende nachfrage aus china die jetzt
mutmaßlich noch weiter zurückgehen wird
auch schon einzelne nachrichten über
kurzarbeit vor corona gehabt aber nicht
in dem ausmaß und deshalb zu den
einzelnen weiteren instrumenten ja auch
im gesetz sind im haben dass arbeit von
morgen gesetzes wenn wir morgen
informieren heute geht es erstmal um die
konjunkturellen regeln im bereich
kurzarbeit nur einen einzigen satz wir
haben ja eine hotline des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums für die
unternehmen dort rufen derzeit im
schnitt über 100 unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer täglich an sind vor allen
dingen kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen und die fragen beziehen sich
im schwerpunkt erstens auf die
zurverfügungstellung von kurzfristige
liquiditätshilfe darauf sind wir bereits
vorbereitet und zweitens auf die
regelungen beim kurzarbeitergeld und das
werden wir jetzt so schnell wie möglich
verfügbar machen
das ist verwegen da bitte
[Musik]
ich fange mal mit dem erst dann sagt
dann auch was zu home office es ist von
unserem zeitplan her so ich sag noch mal
aber wir müssen respekt haben vor den
parlamenten die wir jetzt um mithilfe in
dieser situation auch übrigens
parteiübergreifend bitten dass wir das
ziel haben dass durch den beschluss des
kabinetts heute das ist heute mittag um
12 basiert und die parallel einbringen
durch die fraktionen die heute
nachmittag möglich wird durch die
fraktionssitzung bereits am kommenden
freitag den bundesrat und bundestag mit
dem gesetz tatsächlich im rahmen der
fristen beschäftigen werden das sind die
sogenannten ersten lesung
es muss die möglichkeit geben natürlich
findet parlament im zweifelsfall auch
anhörung zu machen
das kann dann am montag der nächsten
sitzungswoche zum beispiel stattfinden
so ist das mit den koalitionsfraktionen
jedenfalls vorgesprochen so dass für den
abschluss der zweiten dritten lesung
dann in der kommenden sitzungswoche des
bundestages haben dann ist der bundesrat
noch mal dran nach unserer ordnung und
dann haben wir als bundesregierung die
verordnungsermächtigung die wir dann in
kraft setzen können
und wenn sie ein bisschen rechnen dauert
das alles ungefähr drei wochen
das reicht aber auch aus weil der
bestehende kurzarbeit regeln wie gesagt
schon haben und dann haben wir aber
zügig die möglichkeiten
für unternehmerinnen unternehmer und für
beschäftigte die sich mit dem thema
jetzt beschäftigen aus akuter situation
heraus kann man nur raten sich wirklich
an die örtliche bundesagentur für arbeit
zuwenden die kann über die bestehenden
kurzarbeitsregelung aufklären und sie
wird über den informationsfluss den wir
mit der bundesagentur jetzt
sicherstellen
in den nächsten tagen auch über mögliche
weitere regelung der gesetzgeber und der
verordnungsgeber dann geben werden
informieren zum einzelnen habe ich
vorhin die beschlüsse der koalition ja
genannt
es ist bisher um zum beispiel zu sagen
so das kurzarbeitergeld und der
voraussetzungen gezahlt werden kann wir
senken jetzt wie gesagt die schwelle so
genannte drittel erfordernis ein drittel
der mitarbeiter müssen verkürzt sein ab
auf 10 prozent das heißt der zugang das
zu beantragen für unternehmen geht
einfacher das zweite ist dass wir auch
bei den arbeitszeitkonten eine regelung
vorsehen die das einfach ermöglicht das
sind also sozusagen die kategorien
vereinfachung das dritte wird sein dass
wir mehr geld zur verfügung stellen im
zweifelsfall das heißt neben dem
kurzarbeitergeld auch die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge übernehmen
werden und zwar vollständig das ist der
beschluss der koalition darüber hinaus
wie gesagt werden wir zeit arbeiten wir
und arbeitnehmer einbeziehen und die
möglichkeit dass besteht bisher nicht
dass besteht auch erst wenn die
verordnungsermächtigung da ist das sind
die wesentlichen dinge die wir
ermöglichen werden zur frage von mobilen
arbeiten nenne ich das jetzt mal oder
home office es gibt rechtlich wir
diskutieren darüber in anderem
zusammenhang ein rechtsanspruch auf home
office oder mobiles arbeiten
das gibt es vielleicht irgendwann mal
wenn wir uns dazu entschließen aber es
gibt jetzt schon die möglichkeit für
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer dass wenn
das möglich ist zu vereinbaren ich kann
nur sagen wer sich krank fühlt und das
betrifft jetzt atemwegserkrankungen der
kann ja beispielsweise sich auch krank
melden falls das der fall ist
im sinne einer eines einer verordnung
alle mobil zu hause arbeiten zu lassen
kann ich mir das im jetzigen zeitpunkt
überhaupt nicht vorstellen
wir müssen auch ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir bei aller vorsorge vor
infektionen unser gesellschaftliches und
wirtschaftliches
eben nicht lahmlegen wir haben größere
teile der wirtschaft da ist home office
auch im sinne von produktionen gar nicht
wirklich ich bin auch der minister für
arbeitsschutz wir sind auch im gespräch
mit jens spahn der für gesundheitsschutz
zuständig ist wir tun alles
menschenmögliche an dieser stelle das zu
machen und den hintergrund den hat der
kollege sparen und den hat der chef des
robert koch instituts der gestern noch
mal erläutert wir haben den virus jetzt
in deutschland wir können die
ausbreitung nicht vollständig stoppen
aber wir können durch besonnenes handeln
und durch gezielte maßnahmen den verlauf
dieser epidemie die eine pandemie wird
nicht durch aus verzögern
und dafür sind maßnahmen auf den weg
gebracht worden das primäre ziel ist
dass wir damit unser gesundheitssystem
in die lage versetzen das zu bewältigen
und übrigens die regelversorgung auch zu
sichern das ist das prioritäre ziel der
gesundheitsschutz der bevölkerung
wir machen jetzt flankierende massnahmen
für die wirtschaftliche und
arbeitsmarktpolitische stabilisierung in
dieser situation aber ich sage jetzt zu
dem jetzigen zeitpunkt kann ich nicht
raten dass wir das gesamte leben in
deutschland allein auf das
zuhausebleiben beziehen das mag in
bestimmten regionen der fall sein und in
bestimmten situationen aber nicht
generell für deutschland ja ich bin auch
hier völlig einer meinung mit dem
kollegen hubertus heil
erstens ist unbestritten dass
gesundheitsschutz vorrang hat vor
wirtschaftlichen erwägungen
das ist die gemeinsame meinung der
bundesregierung und wenn jemand sich
unwohl fühlt bzw
von diesem virus betroffen ist dann ist
es vor allen dingen notwendig auf die
gesundheit zu achten und die wieder
herzustellen
im übrigen müssen unternehmen auch einen
gewissen freiraum haben zu entscheiden
was die sinnvolle maßnahme ist es mag
fälle geben beispielsweise in
großraumbüros wo man zum ergebnis kommt
die möglichkeit von home office
anzubieten es wird andere fälle geben wo
es keinen sinn macht oder auch in der
sache gar nicht funktioniert und deshalb
hat auch ich eine generelle regelung in
diesem fall nicht für angebracht
ich glaube wir geben noch mal angesichts
der lage vielleicht drei möglichkeiten
zu fragen dazu ist das okay da man das
können wir von heute vollständig nicht
prognostizieren
ich kann nur sagen dass wir als
koalition und das werden wir auch
umsetzen im gesetz erst mal gesagt haben
dass für die verordnungsermächtigung bis
ende 2021 ermöglichen
und dass wir uns politisch verabredet
haben dass die erste verordnung die wir
jetzt in kraft setzen werden bis ende
des jahres erstmal gilt die kann
jederzeit verlängert werden das ist
alles dann kein hexenwerk da sind wir in
der bundesregierung stelle im
zweifelsfall per umlaufbeschluss in der
lage zu handeln
aber das ist der zeitraum den wir jetzt
erstmal den blick nimmt und im übrigen
bekommen wir laufen informationen über
die entwicklung der
volkswirtschaftlichen situation was
einfuhren und ausfuhren angeht
produktions auf die eingänge und
betrifft das werden wir sehr genau
verfolgen wir werden ja in wenigen
wochen auch die frühjahrsprognose der
bundesregierung bekannt geben und so
werden wir ruhig und besonnen aber
schritt für schritt in voller
transparenz und nachvollziehbarkeit die
lage jeweils neu bewerten
herr kreuzburg bitte
kurz zur historie zweitens zur sache ja
ich habe im sommer letzten jahres
eckpunkte für eine arbeit von morgen
gesetz für einen instrumentenkasten für
den strukturwandel zu
arbeitsmarktpolitischen begleitung
vorgelegt das soll und ist teil der
nationalen weiterbildungs strategie
ich hatte dann anfang november einen
gesetzentwurf darauf vorgelegt mit dem
kanzleramt übermittelt haben von dem ich
wusste dass wir darüber reden müssen
weil das zum teil nicht im
koalitionsvertrag verankert waren in der
damaligen version waren übrigens auch
alle verordnungsermächtigung für
konjunkturelle einbrüche drin das ist
dann im wege des verhandlungstags mit
der ansage falls mal sowas kommt können
wir schnell handeln dann wieder
rausgekommen und wir haben uns
konzentriert auf den strukturwandel das
heißt in dem instrumentenkasten unter
anderem einen transformationsprozess für
das qualifizierungs chancen gesetz
regelungen zu transfergesellschaften und
im falle von kurzarbeit die verbindung
mit mit weiterbildung der war dann die
möglichkeit ihre manens kosten die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu
übernehmen das ist auch weiterhin im
gesetz drin wir reden über eingesetzt
hier aber wir bauen jetzt die regeln die
verordnungsermächtigung für das
konjunkturelle kurzarbeitergeld weiter
aus zu bestehenden recht und das heißt
ich werde sie morgen über details dieses
gesetz ist das ein paar anderen
maßnahmen hat informieren wir haben uns
am sonntag in der koalition entschieden
dass wir das in
ein gesetzesentwurf machen und auch
behalten um die öffentlichkeit auch
nicht über verschiedene kurzarbeits
regeln
die parallelen gesetzgebungen laufen
würden zu verwirren
der instrumentenkasten ist teil der
gesamtveranstaltung das gesamte gesetz
ist wie gesagt heute vom kabinett in der
form wie es eben beschrieben aber auf
den weg gebracht worden
naja also was die liquiditätshilfen
angeht haben wir ja eine gültige
regelung die über die kfw läuft dann
abgewickelt würde steht zur verfügung im
übrigen bin ich mit dem kollegen olaf
scholz dabei diese regelung zu
evaluieren und gegebenenfalls auch die
dafür zur verfügung stehenden
finanziellen mittel aufzustocken werden
sie gemeinsam olaf scholz und peter
altmaier im laufe dieser woche über
anstehende verbesserungen und änderungen
informieren
zu ihrer ersten frage von rosbach
anschließend kann ich auch sagen
kurzarbeitsregelung sind auch eine
liquiditätshilfe es geht darum
liquidität durch die übernahme von
personalkosten bei arbeitsausfall zu
unterstützen
noch einmal es gibt die bestehenden
regeln dass der schnellste weg und der
politisch sicherste der uns eingefallen
ist nach langer beratung und ich will
auch sagen dass sie das daran sehen
können dass das kabinett jetzt nicht bis
morgen gewartet hat und das zu einer
ordentlichen kabinettssitzung
beschlossen hat sondern heute in der
lage war gestern ihre so abstimmung
tatsächlich in wenigen stunden zu machen
zweitens heute das zu machen wenn ich
jetzt versucht hätte das was wir
vorbereitet hatten letzte woche für den
koalitionsbeschluss noch einmal
auseinander zufrieden weil das
gesetzgeberische bezüge aufeinander sind
hätten wir mit sicherheit zeit verloren
und wir haben jetzt den schnellsten weg
weil wir am freitag wie gesagt mit den
fristen die in unseren parlamenten
maximal mit der bitte um fristverkürzung
ausgeschöpft sind am freitag bereits den
bundesrat zu erreichen und deshalb ist
das der schnellste und beste weg der da
ist das verlangt einigen einiges ab auch
dass es weniger diskussions zeit für die
anderen instrumente gibt aber es wird
eine ordentliche parlamentarische
beratung geben es gibt auch ausschuss
anhörungs möglichkeiten und es war allen
beteiligten auch wichtig zumal man dann
auch bei der opposition nicht das
beschneiden kann deshalb sind alle
möglichkeiten da das sehr schnell und
zügig zu beratenden kraft zu setzen ist
das zügige verfahren auf das wir kommen
konnten
herr buchsteiner bitte
das buch stand zu ihrer im zusammenhang
nochmal ich will wert darauf legen dass
wir in deutschland für solche
konjunkturellen oder wirtschaftlichen
störungen
zwei dinge haben die vielleicht schon
mal sehr gewirkt haben die andere länder
nicht immer in dieser form haben das
erste ist wir haben einen sozialstaat
der im zweifelsfall auch als
automatischer stabilisator wirkt das
heißt das dass ausreichend von
sozialleistungen solchen konjunkturellen
störungen wirtschaftlich stabilisierend
wirkt selbst wenn menschen arbeitslos
werden sollten was wir verhindern werden
und wollen gibt es jetzt zum beispiel
arbeitslosengeld das kennen andere
länder nicht und das stabilisiert im
zweifelsfall auch die wirtschaftliche
situation die nachfrage das haben wir
jetzt 289 auch erlebt dass der
sozialstaat als sicherungssystemen
wirtschaftlich nicht nur sozial
funktioniert das zweite ist dass ich
ihnen diese rechnung so einfach nicht
machen kann das will ich ihn vor rechnen
das kurzarbeitergeld um fast 60 prozent
der arbeitsentgelt leistung bei familien
67 prozent und jetzt müsste ich ihre
rechnung ihr wissen auf der die gehalte
bezogen der betroffenen unternehmen und
branchen um das 400.000 als äquivalent
zu machen
es kommt darauf an in welchen branchen
das ist um die lohn gehaltsstruktur ist
ich kann ihnen nur abstrakter folgende
rechnung aufmachen
uns hat das institut für arbeitsmarkt
und berufsforschung bei einem früheren
gesetz mal simuliert und durchgerechnet
wie für rücklagen die bundesagentur für
arbeit bräuchte um ich sage mal eine
mittelschwere krise über ein paar jahre
zu überstehen und die aussage waren 0,65
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts und
das sind ungefähr 20 milliarden euro
wir haben jetzt 26 milliarden euro das
es besser gepolstert als 2008 9 wo wir
diese situation der rücklage nicht
hatten
das heißt wir halt eine stunde ganze
länge strecke durch ohne dass wir auf
den bundeshaushalt zurückgreifen müssen
das ist jetzt eine gute nachricht für
olaf scholz
diese brücken aus den
sozialversicherungen
in diesem fall aus der
arbeitslosenversicherung zu bauen wir
sind gewappnet auch für einen längeren
zeitraum
kurzarbeit ist immer eine brücke das
muss man wissen und wir sind auch in der
lage diese brücke ziemlich lang zu bauen
wenn es notwendig ist aber wir hoffen
natürlich dass das nicht über viele
jahre dauern wird sondern ein zeitraum
den wir im blick haben zu überbrücken ja
also auch ich gehe davon aus dass es
darum geht ein konjunkturelles problem
zu überbrücken von dem wir nicht genau
wissen wie lange es uns beschäftigen
wird aber die erfahrungen aus 2008 2009
haben uns gezeigt dass es eine win win
situation für alle beteiligten ist
wir haben beim staatlich
staatlicherseits höhere aufwendungen aus
den rücklagen der bundesagentur das ist
richtig auf der anderen seite vermeiden
wir einnahmeausfälle bei den
sozialabgaben und steuern die dadurch
entstehen das unternehmen mitarbeiter
entlassen und sie dann bei anziehender
konjunktur mühsam wieder suchen müssen
mit dem ergebnis dass weniger wachstum
entsteht ich glaube das ist
volkswirtschaftlich sehr großen sinn
macht diese maßnahme zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt zu treffen und nein ich glaube
wir sollten jetzt nicht anfangen bereits
beschlossene maßnahmen wieder infrage zu
stellen
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir in dieser
situation ruhig und besonnen das
richtige tun und da wir die grundrente
ja so ausgestaltet haben dass sie die
wirtschaft und die beitragszahler nicht
belastet sondern aus anderen mitteln
finanziert wird ist es glaube ich
richtig dass wir zu dem stehen was wir
als koalition gemeinsam vereinbart haben
das merken sie bei uns beiden und das
gilt für die gesamte koalition ich gehe
davon aus übrigens auch für wirtschaft
und gewerkschaften sind zeiten des
pragmatismus des handelns der
besonnenheit und auch da noch mal die
anlage 2008/9 ich habe vorhin gesagt es
gibt eine sache die geholfen hat die
anderen länder nicht so haben dass unser
sozialstaat aber auch andere länder
kennen dich diese form von
sozialpartnerschaft und wenn wir jetzt
noch mal grundsatzdebatten aufmachen
über bestimmte politikfelder dann würden
wir am problem vorbei gehen ich gehe
davon aus dass bei dem gipfel gehen
die bundeskanzlerin mit uns als
zuständigen ministern und den
sozialpartnern organisieren wird zeitnah
wie wir das besprochen haben dass da
eine große einigkeit ist und ich habe
mich heute auch über die unterstützung
zu den kurzarbeitsregelung aus
wirtschaft und gewerkschaft gefreut
das sind leute die in der lage sind bei
allen interessen unterschieden
pragmatisch zu handeln und ich kann nur
daran appellieren dass wir das jetzt
auch tun was wir beide nicht machen
und wofür im politischen bereich auch
nicht anderen raten können ist jede
forderung wie man schon mal hat mit
corona zu begründen das hat es in den
letzten tagen auch gegeben dass es nicht
ernsthaft sondern wir haben denn
angemessen und zielgenau mit den
instrumenten die wir jetzt wirtschafts
und arbeitsmarktpolitisch brauchen und
das ist auch glaube ich vernünftig so
herzlichen dank